but you take great care when you're
buying an app to make sure it's good and
it's not going to ruin your machine and
does exactly what you want hTML is the
ultimate example of what you troubled
you get into if you are promiscuous
right you are promiscuous why because
part of all HTML does is you have to
visit other people's websites and you
have to execute not your code that you
wrote other people's code HTML it's an
interpreted system the customers want
instant gratification and you got to get
cracking speed is of the essence I think
the number what we're trying to get at
is this HTML seems to be able to
tolerate your mistakes but for those of
you who know a programming language
basic C or whatever you know they will
not tolerate your mistakes
they won't interpret for you they won't
compile a program for you unless it's
correct so how does this difference come
about if HTML is a language is getting
executed what is it about it that makes
it easy to be tolerant and on the face
of it yes it's wonderful it seems to put
my errors right perhaps we could start
off with our good old friend the
paragraph P and I'm going to just put a
piece of text in here which says hello
Shawn even though I absolutely don't
have to do it never let someone to do it
I want to close off the paragraph and
then I'm going to open up another one
straight away afterwards goodbye Dave
and once again we close off with a slash
P you'll all understand that this is a
classic use of paragraphs you put them
in sequence you have first paragraph
same power third paragraph all that kind
of thing does it mean anything and does
it look any different and does it do any
different if I start messing about and
saying I'm not going to sequence them
I'm going to fit the second paragraph
inside the first so it's nested as we
say it for
a hierarchy it's a para within a para
you can see the difference I've opened
up a paragraph I've said hello Shawn and
then opened up another paragraph and
I've said this is an S just to hammer it
home that the inner Juan really is
fitting inside the outer wall and then I
dutifully closed them both off you might
think oh I know what it'll do
I might get hello Shawn and then the
phrase this is a nest will be tabbed in
and indented maybe that's what it does
so I've tried this out in my own Firefox
browser and believing me it doesn't
crash it it just treats it exactly as if
it was sequential paragraphs there's no
sign of the nesting or anything so if we
develop these a little bit further now
we could say okay do the P hello Shawn
do another P goodbye Dave so you're
omitting the closing bit is that right
I'm knitting the closing of the
paragraphs is that acceptable to HTML
yes it is nothing is going to fault you
for missing out end of P and that if you
type that in will look the same as that
it wants to put the end tags in and
obviously in some sense it does but
what's its rule and here we go it
probably won't do what you want to do it
does what it finds convenient and what
it finds convenient is the following
rule it says I am going to assume if you
give me a second P and I'm already
inside the first one I'll just close the
first one off how would the browser cope
if I sometimes put my end keys in and
sometimes didn't and the answer is it
will always as far as I know assume that
you want to sequence and that is what it
will impose on you what it comes down to
is a sort of informal theorem something
like the following if you're trying to
be very clever and mend somebody's
incorrect program then the problem is
that if you have a structure that can be
a sequence of or it can be a nest of or
it can be any combination you could have
a sequence of nest
or a nest of sequences but if you one
start saying they can both coexist
nesting sequencing then you must put
your end tags in if you want to be
unambiguous otherwise how can it be
repaired so in other words if they if
both possibilities are possible then you
can't have smart behavior because it
cannot know how to repair it correctly
and what hTML is doing is it's not
solving the insoluble it's saying I have
one view of the world and I'm going to
impose it on you and I am NOT going to
try and be clever now that of course is
a luxury that HTML has it basically says
I keep things simple I like things to be
more or less sequential with the minimum
of this embedding you know and all that
and that's why I can get away with
murder now for those of you who have
ever written a program and know that you
compile it or even you interpret it oh
boy it's not going to try and mend your
bad program for you why do the things
are so much more complicated well the
answer is you can do more with these
languages and you will want to do more
let me just invent a little piece of
pseudocode and I'll let you fill this in
in either basic or C or Java or whatever
terms you want printf hello Shawn C
programmers will know that if you want a
new line at the end of that which you do
you better put a backslash n at the end
we're going round the stuff inside this
block which is a very simple block it's
just got a single print statement in it
so what we'll get is hello Jean hello
Jean Jean Jean ten times then I do
another loop that goes around ten times
good bye Dave new line close quotes
semicolon let's hope this friendly would
compile you can all see what's going to
happen when you execute this I'm going
to get this wrong I don't know Jean I've
shown 10 times then goodbye Dave goodbye
Dave goodbye Dave goodbye Dave ten times
so that is what happens when you have a
sequence of blocks but by comparison
with paragraph in
EML can you in programming languages
have nested blocks you bet you can now
I'm going to say loop around ten times
on the following printf sure but now
look at what I'm going to do I'm now not
going to close off that block I'm going
to nest another loop block inside it
goodbye Dave
now let's make sure our brackets match
I've opened up one I've opened up two
I've closed this one I must close that
one I hope you can all see and
understand what I'm trying to do here
I'm trying to do a loop within a loop
they're nested like sort of Russian
dolls one inside the other but the
effect of this is completely different
to the one I did previously here what's
going to happen is the outermost one
goes around ten times and every time it
goes around it there's a hello Sean but
every time he doesn't hello Sean it then
goes into a nested in a loop that does
ten good bye Dave's so for every one
hello Sean I print out our magazine ten
goodbye days net result I will end up
with a hundred goodbye Dave's
interleaved between ten hello Sean's
whereas in the earlier case I had twenty
printouts I had ten l Oh Sean's followed
by ten goodbye days lots of students
have said to me over the years the C
compiler so clever why can't it put my
programs right for me and the answer is
if you omit your end tags how can it
know whether you want this one or this
one they're both equally valid this then
is the absolute fundamental conundrum
can you unambiguously put back the
closed curly braces if users omit them
no you can't because you've got to work
out do they want her sequence and s the
nest of sequences there's all sorts of
places to put back the brackets and they
have all sorts of different effects and
that is why C Java basic whatever have
to be theological and
start laying down the law to you
brackets mismatch or whatever whenever
you miss them out the reason let's say
it again
why HTML can be so tolerant is because
it's so much simpler than C it is a
programming language it is an execution
environment but it's not been built to
support deeply nested hierarchical
structures so although it seems to be
tolerant and although it seems to be
correcting your program you've got to
remember it isn't really doing the
impossible it's imposing a model on you
and hoping that the visual effect of
what it does is so stunning that you
won't notice that it's not quite and on
what you hoped it would do
one came along applied one of these two
imagenet and got incredible results and
so on so forth and now there's this big
push and everyone's trying to get you
met results the embedded sauce